buenos días desde cali angela la
situación continúa siendo complicada y
como bien dices sí que estuvimos hierven
durante el día de ayer en siloé donde el
lunes murieron tres personas según la
comunidad y donde parece que ha vuelto a
ser el epicentro de los enfrentamientos
en la noche del martes donde los vecinos
han denunciado ya han publicado vídeos
en redes sociales les puede volver a
haber accionar de armas de fuego por
parte de la fuerza pública y es que la
situación como comentaba deportiva será
complicada y aunque puede haber bajado
un poco la intensidad en otros puntos el
alcalde jorge iván ospina en un llamado
internacional en una videoconferencia
que fue filtrada por redes a embajadores
y organizaciones humanitarias para que
le presten ayuda ya que la situación
está descontrolada y la verdad no parece
increíble a distribuir próximamente está
concepto hoy está convocado aquí quiere
el resto del país un paro nacional
pues muchas gracias por su reporte y
continuaremos recibiendo las
actualizaciones desde cali